et nous continuons à parler santé
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale
des donneurs de sang le ffs a organisé
un pot occasions différentes initiatives
et ce mardi 14 juin une collecte a eu
lieu à l'hôtel de ville d'elancourt plus
d'une cinquantaine de personnes se sont
déplacées pour l'occasion le ffs avait
lancé le 2 juin dernier un appel
d'urgence en prévision des besoins pour
cet été mais aussi en raison de l'euro
2016 à l'établissement français du sang
a besoin de dix mille dont journalier
chaque année ce sont un million de
patients qui sont soignés grâce aux
collectes écoutez les réactions
recueillies sur place par camille
lambert
en bas il est certain qu'on a toujours
besoin de produits sanguins
quand même des maladies qui qui se
soigne uniquement avec des produits
sanguins en a pas d'autre solution pour
les personnes contre l'anémié personnes
qui sont opérés personnes pour un
déficit conjugué talent facteurs de
coagulation
onac les produits sanguins il ya
tellement de gens qui ont besoin de sens
pour les opérations pour participer aux
nécessités qui en cent pour ceux qui en
ont besoin
on je peux moi me permettre de donner